-Welcome, everybody. Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show." You're here. You made it.
♪♪
Let's get to some news. Well, guys, President Biden says
that he plans to run for re-election in 2024.
Meanwhile, at a rally this weekend,
President Trump also hinted at running.
It's big news, but all I can think about is Taylor Swift
being on the show tonight, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So you know what that means.
It's time for "The News (Taylor's Version)."
Here we go. [ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
So, Biden and Trump are both running for re-election,
and they've got major "bad blood,"
which everyone knows "all too well."
Of course, Trump has quite the "reputation."
Every other day, he's like, "I did something bad,"
and Biden has to be like,
"This is why we can't have nice things,"
which is why this could be the most dramatic election
ever -- more -- Importantly --
"Evermore" importantly, they both need running mates.
Biden is looking at Kamala like, "You belong with me,"
while Trump is looking at Mike Pence like,
"We are never ever getting back together."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Like, ever.
Pence is actually considering a run of his own,
but everyone is like, "I forgot that you existed."
[ Laughter ]
"Long story short," everyone is tired of politics.
But, hey, "you need to calm down,"
"shake it off," and get "ready for it,"
because "'tis the damn season." So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go get your voting "card again,"
head to the polls --
Yeah, that was a stretch, that one.
Head to the polls and fill in every "blank space."
It doesn't matter if you're blue or "red"
or even a "lavender haze."
You've got to let your voice be heard,
both in 2024 and during the midterms in "'22."
This has been "The News (Taylor's Version)."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
"Card again." -Yeah.
-No, that was awful. That was a stretch there.
Yeah, that's right. Biden intends to run again.
And in a recent interview on MSNBC, he was asked
about his concerns over his age.
Check out the President's response right here.
-I think it's a legitimate thing to be concerned
about anyone's age, including mine.
That's not how I feel.
I can't even say the age I'm gonna be.
I can't even get it out of my mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-I've heard of people dancing around their age,
but I've never seen someone
actually dance around their age, like...
[ Laughter ]
Eventually, a middle-school nun stepped in like,
"Leave room for the Holy Ghost.
Leave -- Leave room for the Holy Ghost."
Secret Service didn't know what to do.
They were like, "Should we step in or give them alone time?
What's the call here?" [ Laughter ]
Some more political news -- over the weekend,
former president Trump held a rally in Texas,
and I noticed that he had some trouble
with the word "smuggler." Watch this.
-They've deliberately surrendered our border
to vicious coyotes and drug smaller --
I mean, these drug smug--
The smuggler. A smuggler!
[ Laughter ]
-"These drug snugglers -- drug smuckers --
drug snickerdoodles, they --" [ Laughter ]
He sounds like he took whatever illegal drug
is being "smullered" across the border.
Sounds like a guy trying to do his first Wordle.
It's like, "Small? Smug? Is smulg a word?
I'm gonna try 'smulg' anyway. Why not?
Let's see. Oh, I'm very smart."
Speaking of Trump, the January 6th Committee
announced that they have subpoenaed the former president.
Yep, Trump's already bragging like,
"I've got the biggest subpoena.
I've been saying it for years.
Nobody's subpoena is bigger than mine."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the committee was like,
"Here's a federal document that you can keep."
Yeah. [ Audience groans ]
Some big news from overseas -- today, Britain announced that
Rishi Sunak is going to be their new prime minister
after Liz Truss lasted only six weeks in office.
Yeah, when he showed up to his new office, people were like,
"You can unpack your things, but I wouldn't hang up
anything on the walls." [ Laughter ]
Yeah, on Thursday, after 45 days in office,
Liz Truss announced her resignation
as prime minister of Britain.
Let's take a look back
on all the greatest moments of Liz Truss.
♪♪
-Good afternoon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, some sports news -- the World Series matchup
is set with the Houston Astros
taking on the Philadelphia Phillies.
[ Cheers and applause ] And, of course --
♪♪
Of course, the fans from Philadelphia are super pumped.
Check out this video.
-Let's go, Philly! [ Laughter ]
-I'm feeling great!
Four more dub!
-Come on, Phillies!
Four more! World Series, baby!
-We got married on Friday, and the Phillies won!
-This is the best part of the weekend by far!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh! "By far"?
-"By far." -Oh, my God.
-A lot of people have videos of the moment they got married,
but very few have a video of the moment
their marriage fell apart. You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Finally, scientists in Japan have gotten closer to finding
a cure for baldness after they were able
to grow hair follicles in a lab.
Well, they actually grew them just outside the lab,
then they combed them over into the lab.
Some fun holiday news --
Mariah Carey just announced that, this December,
she's playing a Christmas show at Madison Square Garden.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mariah Carey Christmas show in New York City.
When they heard that, The Rockettes were like,
"Stay in your lane, girl!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Stay in your lane!"
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-So, if you want to hear "All I Want for Christmas is You,"
you can either go to the concert
or any CVS from now until January.
There you go. [ Laughter ]
Some other New York news -- yesterday, Senator Ted Cruz
was on "The View," and he got heckled and cursed at
by some people in the audience.
[ Cheers ]
Don't worry -- after a few minutes,
security was able to remove Joy and Whoopi from the set,
and so then... [ Laughter ]
Some of the hecklers were climate activists.
The rest were a group of moms who were mad that Ted Cruz
was the guest they were seeing on "The View."
It's like, "Come on!" [ Laughter ]
Some news from Washington -- today, President Biden
got the updated COVID booster shot
and encouraged Americans to do the same.
That's right -- a 79-year-old getting a shot on TV.
You know how excited everyone was for Taylor Swift's
album to drop? This wasn't like that.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, this was Biden's fifth COVID shot.
Most Americans are like, "I'm just gonna wait
till they all come out and binge 'em all at once."
[ Laughter ]
Well, I saw this today -- Bob Woodward released
an audiobook of his 20 interviews
with former president Trump, called "The Trump Tapes."
And I didn't know this, but apparently, at one point,
Woodward asked Trump some rapid-fire questions.
Have you heard of this? -Really?
-Yeah, it's fascinating. Take a listen to this.
-Yeah, just very interesting. Rapid-fire questions.
-Wow. -Pillsbury Doughboy.
-Wow! -Guys, this is very exciting.
We're only six days away from Halloween.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I heard that some of this year's most popular costumes
are Spider-Man, the "Stranger Things" kids,
and dinosaurs, while the least popular is Anti-Semitic Guy.
And, uh... [ Audience groans, laughs ]
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ] -Least popular.
The least popular costume. -Yeah.
-Yeah. Everyone is talking about this --
today, after weeks of public pressure, Adidas finally ended
their partnership with Kanye West
due to his anti-Semitic remarks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think we finally answered the question,
"Is there such a thing as bad publicity?"
Yes, I think there is. Yep, Kanye has now lost
his deals with Adidas, Balenciaga, and Manischewitz.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey! -And now Gap also announced
that they're pulling all Yeezy products from their stores.
[ Audience oohs ] Yep.
Meanwhile, TJ Maxx is like, "We'll sell whatever ya got."
[ Laughter ]
"We let it rip in this place."
Some more business news -- the Federal Trade Commission
wants to hold the CEO of alcohol delivery service Drizly
accountable for a 2020 data breach.
In response, Drizly released this statement.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay. Alright.
Well, get this -- I read that Apple is now selling a door lock
for your house that you can unlock with an iPhone.
Yep, so in case you lose your iPhone,
make sure to keep a spare one under the mat.
[ Laughter ]
Breaking into someone's home is about to be super easy.
Just stand on the porch and yell, "Siri, unlock house!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, a new report says that, since the pandemic,
people have gotten worse at interacting with each other.
I don't think that's true. Do you agree with that, Tariq?
-Good.
[ Laughter ]
-Off to a bad start. Higgins, how you been?
-Thanks. You too. [ Laughter ]
-All right, 0 for 2. One last try.
Let's go with Mike, the camera guy. How are you doing?
-I'm well, Jimmy. Thanks for asking.
[ Cheers and applause ] -There you go.
Finally, a normal response.
Well, this is wild. Due to a broken elevator,
five tourists were stuck in a Grand Canyon hotel
for over a day, 200 feet underground.
Yep, the only person in a deeper hole is Kanye West.
Today, President Biden held a meeting at the White House
with Israeli President Isaac Herzog.
Biden and Israel's president spent hours together.
They discussed Iran, Russia,
and all of their favorite tracks off the new Taylor Swift album.
[ Laughter ]
"Lavender Haze."
Meanwhile, earlier today, President Biden also announced
a plan to cut hidden bank and credit-card fees
in an effort to give families more breathing room.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ] Good.
More breathing room. Interesting. Yeah.
"Breathing room" sounds like
Biden's launching his own line of Skims.
To be honest, I don't know if Biden
is the best person to talk about giving people breathing room.
But I don't know. Maybe I'm wrong. I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Biden also said that he's looking to get rid of
added fees on cable bills.
That's great news.
[ Cheers and applause ] That's great news.
Great news for the three people who still have cable.
It's amazing news.
Some more news -- Russia just notified the U.S.
that they would be launching nuclear-capable missiles
as part of their annual nuclear exercise.
Russia is just like us --
they also exercise only once a year.
It's great.
But the U.S. is keeping a close eye on Russia.
Yesterday, Biden said that it would be
a "serious, serious mistake"
for Russia to use nuclear weapons.
Wow. I haven't heard words that powerful
since FDR called Japan's attack on Pearl Harbor
a "major no-no." [ Laughter ]
That's right. Biden said that if Russia uses nuclear weapons
they would be making a "serious, serious mistake."
Yep. And he didn't stop there.
Next he said, "For realsies, you better not."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-No. He went on. -Oh.
[ Applause ]
-"For realsies." -Yeah.
-He went on to say, "But if you wanna really be real,
I'm actually on BeReal.
Just search POTUS and check it out."
And finally, he said, "But seriously, no cap fam.
This behavior is making me salty. Don't @ me."
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is he talk-- I don't know what he's doing.
Guys, I want to say happy birthday to Hillary Clinton,
who turned 75 today.
[ Applause ]
Hillary Clinton.
Of course, Hillary got a lot of texts for her birthday,
and we actually got ahold of some of them.
Yeah, for instance, Ron DeSantis texted...
Next, Vladimir Putin texted...
Then Adidas texted...
"We're giving them away. Free."
Next up, Donald Trump texted...
Bernie Sanders texted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[As Sanders] Send!
[ Applause ]
Next up, Bill Clinton texted...
That's nice.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Joe Biden texted...
"Send!"
[ Applause ]
Nice of everyone to reach out, don't you think?
That's right. Today is Hillary Clinton's 75th birthday.
But I looked it up, and it turns out October 26th
is a lot of people's birthday,
so it's only fair that I wish them all a happy birthday.
This should only take a second.
Feel free to sing along if you want.
[ Clears throat ]
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, dear Hillary Clinton ♪
♪ And Keith Urban ♪
♪ And Seth MacFarlane ♪
♪ And Pat Sajak ♪
♪ And John Heder, a.k.a. Napoleon Dynamite ♪
♪ And Rita Wilson ♪
♪ And Dylan McDermott ♪
♪ And Jaclyn Smith ♪
[ Clock ticking ]
[ Laughter ]
♪ And Bootsy Collins ♪
♪ And Schoolboy Q ♪
♪ And my childhood babysitter, Tiffany O'Brien ♪
[ Clock ticking ]
♪ And professional wrestler C.M. Punk ♪
♪ And former Kenyan President Uhuru Kenyatta ♪
Oh, forget it. I can't do everybody.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, you forgot to mention
that today is my birthday, Jimmy.
-Well, we got a lot of jokes to tell.
Guys --
[ Audience awws ]
Some business -- Some business news.
Today TJ Maxx announced
that they were cutting ties with Kanye West
and no longer selling any of his Yeezy merchandise.
And -- And I personally think I had a small part in that.
Here's a joke that we did from the monologue last night.
This is real.
And now GAP also announced
that they're pulling all Yeezy products from their stores.
-Oh. -Meanwhile, TJ Maxx is like,
"We'll sell whatever ya got.
We let it rip in this place."
Thank you for watching, TJ Maxx.
We love you guys.
-You're a Maxxanista. -Yeah.
Get this, everyone.
Snoop Dogg's professional blunt roller
just revealed that Snoop smokes up to 150 blunts a day.
You know, I'm worried
because if this keeps up, he might form a habit.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I heard about a documentary
about Ed Sheeran in the works. I love Ed Sheeran.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It sounds cool, but I'm not sure the producers
really did their research.
Take a look at the promo they released.
-We're excited to announce a documentary
about one of the world's biggest music stars, Ed Sheeran.
We'll dive into Ed Sheeran's life,
his dedication to music, his hobbies and interests,
and we'll look at never-before-seen photos
of the legendary musician at home and on the road.
"The Ed Sheeran Documentary." Don't miss it.
-You see what I mean? I just feel like --
I feel like they didn't do their homework.
[ Applause ]
Hey, I saw that the new horror series "The Watcher"
is the number-one show on Netflix
for the second week in a row.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Over 270 million hours viewed since its release.
-Wait. Did you say "The Watcher"?
-Yeah. Why? -Well, that's what the guy
who wrote us that letter called himself.
-What letter? -This one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Dearest neighbor at Studio 6B,
allow me to welcome you to the building.
I've been put in charge of watching you.
This message will not be the last.
Your studio is my obsession, and now you are, too.
Who am I? I am the Watcher.
I will never stop watching."
[ Eerie music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
That's so nice of you!
-[ Giggles ] Thanks, Jimmy. I'm a really big fan.
-Oh, nice to see you.
[ Applause ]
He watches. He watches the show.
-That's the Watcher. -Here you go.
-Thank you. Yeah, throw the letter back.
-No problem. -Oh. Got it.
-Well, this is going viral.
An antique furniture gallery showed off a rare
19th-century Italian desk. This is real.
An Italian desk. And it's got a lot of storage space.
Look at this thing.
-First we have here is you press a button,
and the writing slope comes out.
Then, on the sides, you press one of the buttons,
and a secret drawer comes out.
You press another button on the inside,
and secret drawers come out on the end.
Press a button on the side, the lion heads come out.
And then you press a button further here,
and two more drawers come out.
Another drawer at the top.
Press a button, more drawers.
And then you press another button, and another one.
And here's the centerpiece for this one,
where you open it up, the drawers come out.
Of course, these are secret.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry.
That's when you know you got a weed problem.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Update on the story -- Snoop Dogg just moved to Italy.
-Are you serious? -Yep.
The desk also comes with a placard that says...
Well, there's a lot of bad things going on in the news right now,
but it looks like they solved at least one pressing issue.
Watch this. -We'll, you've heard about
horseshoes, but what about horse sneakers?
A new company called Horse Kicks
is now selling high-end sneakers made just for horses.
You'll find lots of the major brands,
like New Balance and Nike Air Jordans.
You can even get your horse sneakers to match your own.
-They have horse sneakers from Nike, New Balance,
and even those gross toe shoes
that everyone's embarrassed to wear in public.
They don't wear them in public. Only at home.
And finally, Costco is selling
the world's largest jigsaw puzzle.
It's 29 feet long, 8 feet tall, and 60,000 pieces.
Yeah, the bottom left corner goes on your coffee table.
The bottom right goes in Zimbabwe.
And a helpful hint. Here's what I did.
Start by taking seven or eight days to find the corner pieces.
Kanye West is in the news.
[ Laughter ]
After losing his deal with Adidas,
Kanye showed up, unannounced, yesterday
at Skechers headquarters and was escorted out.
[ Laughter ]
That's too bad, 'cause if there's one company
that could help him "shape up," it's Skechers.
You know, you'd think --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Yeah, when Kanye showed up, the CEO said, "Call security."
And his assistant was like, "This is Skechers.
We don't have security." [ Laughter ]
I feel like, pretty soon, Kanye's gonna hit up
whoever makes those free paper sandals
after you get a pedicure.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of "Stranger Things," Elon Musk is in the news.
Elon Musk is close to buying Twitter, and yesterday
he walked into their headquarters carrying a sink
just so that he could tweet -- this is real --
"Entering Twitter HQ. Let that sink in."
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Come on.
-That pun cost him $44 billion.
Worth it? I think so.
-Switching gears, uh... [ Laughter ]
After finishing their annual nuclear exercises,
today Vladimir Putin said that Russia would not use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine.
People are like, "Okay. But what about the other countries?"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, of course, it's election season,
and there's a weird story from Pennsylvania.
Apparently, a Democrat named Mike Doyle
is retiring from Congress, and the Republican candidate
to replace him is actually named Mike Doyle.
[ Laughter ]
While the outgoing Democrat, Mike Doyle,
doesn't want the Republican Mike Doyle to win his seat,
so he just released this ad. Take a look.
-Mike Doyle says he'll take care of Pennsylvania voters,
but can we really trust someone like Mike Doyle?
-Hi, I'm Mike Doyle, and I'm a name you can trust,
unlike Mike Doyle.
So, listen to me, Mike Doyle,
and stay the hell away from Mike Doyle.
On Election Day, don't vote for this man,
Mike Doyle -- No, wait.
That's me. Avoid THIS guy. Wait. Is that me or him?
[Bleep] I don't even know anymore.
-This has been a message from
the Mike Doyle Against Mike Doyle PAC.
-Mike Doyle and Mike Doyle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, get this, guys. I heard that Pfizer
is being investigated for allegedly hiding
more than a billion dollars in profit
by transferring money to other countries.
Yeah, not good. Well, in response,
Pfizer went ahead and released this statement, and they said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It sounds serious. -Wow.
-Pfight. -Pfight.
-Pfight -- Pfight me, sorry, yeah.
Well, some entertainment news.
Henry Cavill says that, in his next performance as Superman,
he'll be playing a "enormously joyful Superman."
"Enormously joyful Superman."
We actually have an early clip of enormously joyful Superman.
Take a look at this.
-I know you're trying to find out where I hang my cape.
You won't.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Looks good. I can't wait.
-I can't wait to see it. -Yeah.
I saw a new report that says that people should not rake
all the leaves out of their yard
because it's actually better for your lawn's health.
So, I think, with that in mind,
it's time to say goodbye to my rake.
Rake, are you there?
-A lifetime of autumns together,
and this is how I find out I'm fired.
-Come on, rake. Don't think of it as fired.
Think of it as retiring.
You can now do anything you want.
-Man, I want to rake leaves.
Fall is my whole personality.
-Look, your future is what you make it.
We'll see you in the spring,
when it's time to clear the flower beds.
-You're right, Jimmy.
Hey, we had some good times, though.
Remember high school?
[ Laughter ]
I used to hang out with you and your friends.
Watching you guys play hoops,
hoping you'd take a rake break.
[ Laughter ]
Who was that guy that used to pour out half his Gatorade
then fill the empty half with Yoohoo
and call it Gator-Hoo?
[ Laughter ]
Ed Zipperton. Man, that guy was cool.
-This has been another edition
of "Making James Read Lines He's Never Seen Before."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I miss that rake.
Guys, listen to this.
A new study found that, in the U.S., deli meat is linked
to more than 90% of all listeria cases.
Right now, the CEO of Blimpie is like,
"Well, that's what you get for using real meat."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, this is very interesting.
A new survey found that you can have the best chance
of surviving a zombie apocalypse in Florida.
I wonder why that is.
-[ Scoffs ] Because even zombies
are too afraid to visit Florida.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what? No. You know what? No.
I'm tired of all the Florida slander.
We always make fun of Florida, but I'm putting my foot down.
It's a great state full of great people.
-Listen to this next story. A Florida man
is accused of spiking his co-worker's drink with bleach.
-See? Florida is scary, dude.
-Oh, come on. I'm sure he had a perfectly good reason.
-He confessed to deputies, saying he wanted
to get back at his co-worker for "being difficult."
[ Laughter ]
-"Being difficult"?
-That's just one guy.
It's a random workplace incident.
Not everyone in Florida is chasing people around,
trying to hurt them.
-A Florida man is accused of chasing two people with knives.
[ Laughter ]
-You're done. You're done, man. Case closed.
-I mean -- I mean, it was just only a knife.
-They say he didn't stop with the knives.
He also grabbed an axe.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm telling you, man, Florida is scary!
-That's a fluke between a few people.
It's not like he was knocking on doors in the wee hours
of the morning while wielding a machete.
-A man in a South Florida neighborhood knocking on doors
in the wee hours of the morning while wielding a machete.
[ Laughter ] -Come on.
-Look, at least they're keeping it within state lines.
You know, it's not like they're coming to your house
and stealing the food out of your mouth.
-Three Florida men were arrested in a multimillion-dollar
theft ring of stolen meat across the Midwest.
-What's your excuse this time?
-Maybe they were -- they were giving the food to the needy.
-The men were selling the meat on the black market.
-Alright, forget it! Let's talk about something else!
I'm not -- I'm tired of it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, Essentia water has teamed up
with a boxed-wine company
to sell water and wine in one box.
Look at this.
Yeah.
In a related story, they're currently being sued by Jesus.
This weekend is Halloween.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was so touched this morning.
A kid who lives in my neighborhood
put on a fake patchy beard and said he was going as me.
Isn't that nice?
[ Laughter ]
I read that this is expected to be
the biggest Halloween since the pandemic.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ] Yeah. That's right.
Now that COVID is under control,
kids can safely return to eating food from strangers.
That's what I'm talking about.
People are going all-out.
I saw that costume spending alone
projected to hit a record of $3.6 billion.
[ Audience oohs ] 3.6 billion.
To put that in perspective,
that's almost half as much as Kanye lost this week.
-Oh. -$3.6 billion.
A lot of --
Almost half. [ Laughs ]
That's right. Halloween is almost here.
You probably heard a lot of good advice
about how to safely enjoy the holiday,
but you have to be on the alert
because there's a lot of bad advice out there, too.
So, here with some terrible Halloween advice
is our sound engineer, Steve Mandel.
Steve?
-Only trick-or-treat at houses with large dogs.
If they bite,
you could be looking at a pretty sweet lawsuit.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Steve.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ] Let's get to some news.
Everybody's talking about this.
Last night, Elon Musk finally closed his deal to buy Twitter.
[ Audience groans ] Yeah.
Now he owns SpaceX if he wants to see the heavens,
and he owns Twitter if he wants to see hell.
[ Laughter ] It's amazing.
The first thing Elon did -- this is true -- after taking over
was fire a bunch of executives.
Yeah, people said he was cleaning house.
Then Elon was like, "I'm a billionaire.
I don't know what those words mean."
Meanwhile, Russian and Chinese state media figures
already asked Elon to stop identifying
their accounts as propaganda.
It's always a good sign when Russia and China are like,
"Finally, a guy we can work with."
Some more business news --
due than worse than expected earnings,
I saw that Amazon is no longer a trillion-dollar company.
And just from talking to Alexa,
you can tell that Amazon is suddenly a little light on cash.
I'll show you what I mean. Alexa, what's the weather?
-Alexa: Give me 20 bucks, and I'll tell you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Alexa, I'm not gonna give you 20 bucks.
-Alexa: How about 10 bucks to bet on "FanDoo-el"?
-I'm not gonna do that. I think it's time for you to go.
-Alexa: Whatever. Check me out on OnlyFans.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
-Alexa...
-Guys, did you see that Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
was caught on a hot mic telling President Biden
that Democrats are going downhill in Georgia
as Herschel Walker climbs in the polls.
Yeah, I'm actually not surprised
Herschel Walker is climbing in the polls.
He's somehow the most anti- and pro-abortion candidate
of all time.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on! -Amazing.
-That's a good joke! -Never seen anything like it.
-Wow. -It's tough for Schumer.
You got to try and talk soft enough
so the mic doesn't pick you up
but loud enough so Biden can hear.
I don't blame him.
Why don't we check in with Steve Mandel
for some more bad Halloween advice. Steve?
-Be careful out there.
Sometimes when you think you're buying edibles,
they turn out to just be candy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, listen to this. YouTube just announced
that doctors and nurses can now apply for their videos
to be marked as "reliable."
Well, if you're still unsure of what to believe,
here are some helpful hints to tell whether a YouTube doctor
is reliable or not.
For example, reliable ends videos with...
Brah!
Smash it, brah!
You see, here's another example.
Next up...
"Talk to Kurt. Talk to Kurt."
Reliable...
-Ooh.
-Here's a final example.
I hope those help. I hope that helps you out.
Some sports news -- tonight was game one
of the World Series between the Philadelphia Phillies
and the Houston Astros.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Man, if Ted Cruz thought he got booed harshly in New York,
God help him in Philadelphia. Oh, man.
Yeah, the World Series has kicked off
with the Phillies taking on the Astros.
And both sides are fired up. There's even some trash talking.
Even the mascots are getting in on it.
Yeah. Can we see the mascots? Yeah. It's been pretty heated.
First the Philly Phanatic said...
Then Orbit said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Then the Philly Phanatic said...
Then Orbit said...
Then the Phanatic said...
-Wow!
Uncalled for! Salty.
-Let's check in with Steve Mandel for some bad --
more bad Halloween advice. Steve?
-Don't enter any strange vans, 'cause one of them is my home.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Smoke -- Smoke came out of his mouth when he said "home."
-Home. -Home. Yeah.
-Smoke came out -- Finally, new research shows
that being around birds can improve your mental health.
Yeah, that's why the most relaxing meal of the year
is always Thanksgiving dinner, yeah.